well there you go let's talk politics
now that we talked about Kanye West we
got this story from Vanity Fair how
scared should Democrats be about the
midterms I'll just jump right to the
bottom and I'll explain they say even if
you ignore the eye popping 32-point
swing among Independent Women the new
Republican lead it shows tracks with
other recent polls simply put for some
reason in the past couple of weeks
almost all of the polls have shifted
from Democrat to Republican and now it's
looking like if you if you add that
together with the the the bias in the
polls as it is Red Wave red tsunami so
uh are we excited are we secretly
laughing because we know that
Republicans aren't actually going to do
anything if they do win where are we at
with this I'm
um I don't know if excited is the right
word but I'm satisfied with the change
in politics also changing geographicals
I've been just watching maps of like
countries changing over the years and
like people I think have this idea that
borders are stagnant borders constantly
have changed throughout history and I
think political affiliations political
parties new ones are created old ones go
defunct uh Tulsa gabbard left the
Democratic party I think it's inevitable
that that thing is I mean as people wake
up and see that the the fascist business
collusion with the Democratic party it
becomes kind of apparent that it's not
the good guys not that the people are
bad I think a lot of the people involved
are just involved because they always
have been but you know that that system
is pretty busted up looks like from the
outside so is it more than just the
women or uh you know is it a full shift
there's a full shift across the board
but but a 32 point this is one poll by
the way maybe it's just a bad sample
size but among independent females
32-point swing I mean that's it's insane
yeah I think that so it was plus 14
Democrat and then a couple weeks later
plus 18 Republican wow and I think it
might have to do with schools but I
really do think it just kind of comes
down to gas prices yeah yeah Joe Biden
got caught in a quid pro quo with Saudi
Arabia and then people were just like
I'm sick of it and then you're running
what are you seeing on the ground what
what are your people telling you about
the projections what how are you seeing
this political landscape yeah well in in
Idaho we have
this struggle between what we call
conservatives and Republicans because
everybody in Idaho is pretty much
Republican right literally and so like
the the Deep State The Establishment
well they're Republican well and the
conservatives who want freedom and want
you know want the good things of life
and want this country to be free well
they're conservatives but they're also
Republican and so that's what we're
seeing like kind of this battle of
establishment Republicans versus true
conservatives and uh it's it's very
interesting and the you know the mothers
have a lot to say about it they're
concerned and I don't know if this is
you know nationally why this poll is so
uh so uh
strong when it comes to women but you
know they're worried about their
children they're worried about their uh
you know they're worried about the
future of their children you know that's
constantly on their mind
um I'm sure they don't like paying the
five dollar gas either oh yeah but uh
but I think they have a sense of like if
if we don't do something right now like
uh you know if we don't correct this uh
this is going to get much much worse so
there was a poll where they asked people
would you vote for someone who denied
the election and Democrats
overwhelmingly said no and Republicans
were kind of split I think it's funny
because the Democrat perspective is
Trump and so they just think they're
ragging on Trump but if it's like okay
what about Hillary Clinton she denied
the election several times she still
does to this day and then they're like
oh well you know but I think it's funny
because ultimately the poll found is
that no one cares no one cares about
this stuff they they're they're going to
them and saying like January 6th even
Saturday Night Live was making fun of
the January 6 committee and they called
Adam Schiff the uh a villain from the
horror movie smile and then he was like
we're not even going to let somebody has
to say he's too spooky and they just
skip over him I thought that was funny
just ragging on the guy but hey there
you go the January 6th stuff is so
unappealing that's that Saturday Night
Live thought making fun of it would
actually do well for them and it did
although they did make a joke that
you're you're either a republican who's
not watching it or a Democrat who's
nodding so much your head's falling off
but then they they mock Chuck Schumer
mercilessly and Nancy Pelosi so you know
it is what it is but I think the reality
that they're that they know but won't
let go you know nobody who's voting is
voting because of this I mean look maybe
a handful of people are like we better
we better save our democracy but I
guarantee you
you walk down the street and you say who
are you voting for they're gonna say
republican why gas
okay that's it end of story economics is
always the
seems to be the number one reason uh why
power shifts from one party to the other
yep
how's your how's your race going
particularly like who are you running
against what's the biggest difference
between you and your competitor so I'm
I'm running against the Republican
incumbent
um Brad little and uh he's you know the
The Establishment guy there the Deep
State
um if you will and uh it's kind of a
rhino yeah he's absolutely a rhino uh
you know Idaho was the we we look at
Idaho and I think the rest of the
country looks at Idaho and says hey you
know they're really conservative they're
kind of uh you know more far right
however Idaho was the first state to
arrest pastors for having church outside
during covet wow and we were we we were
the first state to arrest a mother for
going taking her kids to the park uh you
know and it was all done under Governor
Little's lockdown orders and so you know
I mean the difference is
you know it's completely different I
don't believe the way he believes I
don't believe that that's the purpose of
government I believe the purpose of
government is to protect people's rights
not to infringe upon them and uh this is
Idaho yeah this is Idaho you got people
in Oregon who want to leave Oregon and
join Idaho yeah they're they're you know
the bargain of the highways are clear
full of people coming into Idaho it's
the fastest growing State oh yeah in the
country yeah but you know who it is
tell me well we're hearing a lot that
wealthy people are buying up oh yeah
these wealthy you know ranches and
Estates yeah that's prices are insane I
think they're called Kami fornions yeah
and I think there's also a lot of
elitist buying like Doomsday properties
and farming properties and there's also
one guy who loves to you know Force down
fake meat down everyone's throat who's
also buying up a lot of property
everywhere else what's his name
it's like it's like you know he
represents closing of something closing
of Gates or something like that yeah I
wonder who that is so can we not say
that then on this Channel
full disclosure is he I don't know him
I'm gonna stop insulting people's uh
person and start insulting the things
they do yeah there you go because I have
a feeling I'm gonna meet these people
one day you know when Bill Gates was
being interviewed about being on
Epstein's plane and then just went well
he's dead now anyway yeah I was like wow
what a bad guy kind of thing you know
someone lost their life here you know
what I mean like you know Bill come on
you where's your friend
they were very close to the point where
he even divorced his wife because of
their close friendship together you were
saying he's yes you were mentioning I
was your buddy man that was your best
friend and if someone's going to treat
their best friend like that imagine how
they're gonna treat you I just want to
point out real quick that we did the
story about how Bill Gates has
organizations that track mentions of him
uh you know in media so there you go
bill
anyway you were saying what's up Billy
oh man you were mentioning earlier a
difference between conservatives and
Republicans yeah especially in Idaho do
you find that as conservatives that
people tend words toward libertarianism
but that they don't don't adopt the
libertarian party because it's too small
or something uh I don't think that is
too small I think the issue ultimately
is is kind of on abortion like like they
won't go to the libertarian side because
of abortion and also because of kind of
law enforcement really like they just
love law enforcement no matter what they
do
um and this is be the this would be the
establishment and the conservatives like
uh but people are waking up that there's
good law enforcement there's bad uh and
that uh and it can be very dangerous and
so I would say if there was two issues
it would be that it would be you know
libertarian view on on abortion and then
also just law enforcement and their role
and and who they are and what they do so
if you would win the race what's the
first few few things you would do what's
your policies that you're running on how
would you change Idaho so one is is
abortion I mean we have this opportunity
I am absolutely uh for protecting life I
believe that life begins at conception
and so I think that we have to protect
that life so number one or at least
that's the first thing I I will do and
Roe versus Wade being overturned push it
back onto the states so it makes it a
lot easier for me to do that thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there